[Applaudissements]
il est temps de savoir jusqu'à midi le
mérite alors les chéris j'allais faire
un combat allez vous n'avez pas faire un
combat comme ça j'allais faire un combat
parce que je veux que vous oubliez mon
physique
est-ce que vous avez tendance à trop
être sur mon fils on va vous bande et
meyzieu va vous bandé les yeux et vous
allez combattre avec les yeux bandés
d'accord tous les deux attention donc
comment on se sort du riz on se sort du
ring c'est le premier qui charles autres
du ring qui aura gagné mon coeur et vous
on verra pour le week end à deauville
tout à l'heure mais lui je crois qu'il a
passé une belle soirée 2005
cette dizaine en 2025 c'est dans les
chéris attention attention les chiffres
et attention mathieu a mis à l'essai
météo
vim c'est terminé
[Applaudissements]
merci mathieu à les votes le prenez vos
places et paul 11 mai